mr. Phil yes are you sure good how you
doing man you're looking good
check me out I like you man it's my my
stay-at-home beard it's a good look man
you got a good look going on there oh
thanks so uh so I buy the y-you school
training or no well not in the gym
because you know they're not open yet
but hopefully they will be soon but yeah
just getting after in the backyard when
the weather is decent
um we've got some weights but you know
it's nothing like obviously arm dispro
gym so just do what we can try to you
know pivot do different things work on
some stretching and I've been doing yoga
and the telethon and you know just
trying to do you know different stuff to
keep me going
that's uh that's uh I bet it's gotta be
something that's craziness because for
you your office is been you know if you
can't go to the gap it's a how to drive
you nuts it can and initially I would
say it did because you're wondering when
we'll be able to go back and we didn't
have that definitive answer like we're
just now talking about the phase one and
now that gyms are being included in that
they give some more hope but I'm I'm
very thankful that I've acquired some
mature muscle and I know you know what I
mean by that so therefore it doesn't
just go away overnight you know and you
know you acquire this over years of hard
training and diet so the good thing is
that I haven't missed any meals so
that's great and that's a big part of
the game is the meal so Phil you're in
the world I mean I mean I'm in a
financial world and I how's the Fitness
how's the bodybuilding world game you
were hearing all the articles but
24-hour Fitness CEO talking gold get
them GNC what can you tell us with the
current conditions of the fitness
industry well I believe they got hit
harder than what people could ever
imagine
you know there's literally
150 million gym memberships across the
country you know and a lot of people and
that it's not 150 million people it just
people have a lot of memberships to
various gyms and they use it for to get
over depression they use it for
bodybuilding using for all different
types of therapy and it's like they took
their medicine away so those gym owners
I can only imagine what's going through
the 24 Hour Fitness is you've seen
Gold's Gym get affected heavily I
believe they say that they were getting
rid of 30 gyms permanently that's pretty
sad to say permanently quite a few gems
that I know of throughout the country
gym owners who are also some promoters
they're just like I I wish I would have
prepared because now they're looking at
possibly shutting down so it's been very
depressing but very enlightening because
you know obviously watching your content
without you tainment
I wish a lot of those guys would have
you know participated because maybe they
would have been a little bit more
recession-proof or pandemic proof but
then there are those that are pivoting
there are those that are that have
prepared and they will definitely see a
lot of new men new faces once these gyms
reopen the book but the problem is is
that how do we reopen you know the
distancing the the cleanliness is one
thing but the distancing and I've talked
about it with the Dylan Armbruster who
owns the gym I train that are you gonna
scan everybody's face you know the
temperature when they again
the answer is yes like how many people
can you have there per hour are you
going to spread out like equipment
you're going to only allow you know one
person per 5 feet you know instead of
having people on the same step mill or
saint cardio equipment side-by-side are
you gonna have like one every other I
you know that the questions are is
everybody gonna have to wear a mask when
they enter the gym all these things and
it's very interesting you know but the
supplement industry has definitely been
impacted you know obviously was you know
my company Phil Heath labs you know we
just started like freshly after the
vault last year on Amazon Prime day and
I would say the international business
of everything is very very uh
troublesome at this point because just
because we're reopening doesn't mean the
rest of the world is and a lot of the
rest of the world you know their their
GDP is much different than ours so like
how are they gonna spend money and like
party they're not getting the same
bailouts companies here so it's
definitely time to be very patient and
to re-evaluate everything new strategy
yeah it's gonna be I was reading the
article about gold I think it shut down
next a lot of that was Jim shut down
hold on you had mystery that was on the
latest and you are the places let me see
if this audio from Mike and I want to
make sure the audio is coming up did
online so yeah it's gonna be interesting
to see how these guys timid with all the
things that are taking place
I don't know 150 million memberships by
the way that's a pretty big number right
I mean it's a lot of people that you
know have memberships from various gyms
you know you know I - it's crazy when
you really think about it like how many
people which is actually really cool to
know that there was a lot of people that
loved the gym that much that they would
have a gym membership here and one in a
different city - do you know maybe they
have like a soul cycle membership but
you know a body building esque type of
membership membership that allows them
to shoot basketball that may be a 24
hour or whatever it's very interesting
but I would really be curious as to went
to see like that fourth quarter
like who's still around yeah I'm curious
myself because when you were painting
the picture of what are you gonna do at
the gym six speed cardio machines
you're touching metal you white metals
or somebody go on it's very technical I
never thought of that
Ron Young honest you know like in with
it I guess we've always been in the
dirty
back in the gym and talking to you know
different gym owners now like they've
all you could go on their instagrams
they're like wiping down the like the
plates some have bought new ones like
they're just like we're starting fresh
I'm like wow some are hiring you know
towel service like what do you do like
you don't want to allow people to maybe
bring in their own towel because maybe
they brought in something from home or
somewhere else so now you have to think
about the towel service that you provide
and right now during that first phase do
we shut down the locker rooms because
the showers could breathe bacteria so
you touching he is like how do you
police this so it's very interesting
amongst other businesses I mean if
you're in an office building you know
like you can you can sanitize things you
could have a cleaning crew coming in
every night this is math but a gym is
completely different so it's um I'm very
I'm beyond casually curious right like
no I wish I was able to sit on one of
those boards of the President's Council
of fitness because I would love to just
listen in on all these business leaders
who lobbied to get the gyms onto that
first phase because initially I believe
they weren't even thought about and then
it was like a massive influx like they
got above bars in certain restaurants
very interesting it is Phil Bamba is my
audio coming out clear or is there a
little bit static man on speakers no
you're you're great clear okay that's
good to know then it's on mine okay so
you know that's the fitness the gym side
house the bodybuilding world doing by
the way everybody else that's watching
this tag your favorite bodybuilder mr.
Olympia and fitness tags M Paul because
they're gonna want to hear what dr. Phil
aka
the gift has to tell us with the current
marketplace and the bodybuilding world I
mean you got shows you know
Dexter Dexter came back from Arnold
Classic right and you know he said that
was the first phase of coronavirus
where's your Expo was shut down but you
got many of them around going on right
now how's the bodybuilding world
handling this they're scrambling I mean
some have been more proactive like you
know obviously what there are no classic
I mean they generate literally believe
it was like over 50 million dollars in
those three days in Columbus Ohio just
in other businesses and stuff so that's
not the vendors that would appear at an
armor sourcing ager Classic in Columbus
Ohio I mean you got they probably have
at least a thousand and then 500 at
least different booths and stuff some
different things that was gone and that
always the artists originated classic
the Arnold Classic is like the kickoff
to the bodybuilding season so right
after that everybody's excited you know
they want to here's my here's my here's
my money I want to buy the the newest
product I want to buy the newest shirt I
want to buy the newest what supplements
do you have like what equipment do you
have it all leads into because you have
that show you have the IRS's show which
is about equipment and whatnot that's in
California you then have the following
month you have the Thibault power which
is in Cologne Germany that is probably
the largest international Fitness Expo
in the world that will shut down they
tried to postpone it and then they're
like we got to focus on 2021 so and they
have our classic usually has like two
holes by two main homes
fibo has over 12 so you can only imagine
like how many countries come there to do
Commerce so all the supplement companies
all the apparel companies have suffered
from not being able to go to these
events those two our largest aside from
the Olympia and now with the current
shows not just in our Federation it's
all Federation's
had to move their events so for us an IV
Pro League they were very proactive
Jemaine and his crew sent down memo
encouraging everybody to contact you
know their their their chairman and work
it out where they can move their dates
as a matter of fact you know I was
having my Phil Heath Classic in Houston
I was moving in from Dallas to Houston
that's April and I luckily moved it to
September with only hoping that it'll
still be available but I tell you what I
had a lot of work that was scheduled a
lot of appearances even for me that you
know a lot of those got cancelled too
you know so some gave me a deposit which
is great thank God other ones I'm sorry
feel like it is so I can only imagine I
know if it affected my pocketbook it
affected everyone so it's an ongoing
thing I definitely believe that if we
can somehow safely get back to normal
hopefully by summer people start feeling
more comfortable and it all revolves
around the rest of the world really it's
not just us with bodybuilding in our
industry it we really have to like focus
on the different countries that aren't
as powerful as us because those
competitors they have it referendum we
do for sure they don't have the same you
know they just don't have the same
society so it's it's I'm speechless like
I can't believe like it is is very it's
very interesting that it's uncharted
territories I guess do you think mr.
Olympia is still going to happen in
September I believe that from what I've
seen that they're on track my concern
would be they have a great product
they've been going around for 56 years
they're gonna for sure have this show
this year I hundred percent believe that
because they've built I mean it's the
standalone like it's its tail India it
has to happen right but I'm sure they
would be heavy on the phones right now
making sure that hey James
was going on Koshien was going on you
know this company this company what's
going on what's going on are you okay
because you need then there's four these
Expos and that's and that's you know a
huge moneymaker for all promoters you
know the partnerships that you've had
for years and years how are you I think
those are the questions that I'm sure
they've been you know asking and and
getting really asking like hey how's
your family like how is everybody okay
what can we do to help mitigate and then
push forward so I would say with the new
owner Jake would I believe that he would
be doing that along with Dan Salomon I'm
confident that they're making those
calls it's just that right now they
don't necessarily have control over the
economy so if there's a hundred
companies that wanted to exhibit a Dan
Olympia which in fact they would
probably also throw money out of speed
some type of sponsor and they just have
to lay off half their staff they're not
thinking about any shows so even if you
took the Olympia out they're not
thinking that's just trying to survive
another month so I I would say what's
like once I would say once June hits you
know I think we'll get a better
understanding that you know none of us
can keep secrets in this industry so
we'll all and all business owners are
calling each other up which is actually
pretty cool like they're saying like hey
you all right you're right like I'm
still alive and I always remember what
what I heard you say about three
weekends ago you were up early on a
Sunday doing a live and you said the
first rule of business is but stay in
business and that's the biggest thing
right now is that the Olympia is gonna
stay in business I'm confident in that
I'm more concerned with the other
companies how do you feel about the new
ownership of mr. Olympia I've known Jake
for a while
saw what he did with the wings of
strength model you know I'm very happy
for actually because you know we you and
I both have talked about this and you've
mentioned this even on your own
that the Olympia of all things has to
have a passionate leader you know
obviously you have to have the finances
and stuff like that but you have to be
very passionate Joe leader was
passionate even some of the other guests
that you've had on great passion people
and Jake is that guy he's a man of very
few words but you could tell that his
passion is strong and I knew like once
his name came up I was like okay at
least we have someone that has been
inside of our sport in some fashion for
quite some time that isn't just thinking
about the the numbers of money and
that's no shot at David you know Packard
but but that's he never you never he
wasn't a bodybuilder you know he wasn't
a Joe reader so I'm very happy for a
Jake you know I wish our friend Dan
Solomon would have told me that mr.
Olympia brand was for sale when I met
with them because other people were
interested but that statement was never
made you know I thought yeah I I thought
I thought for sure nobody had interest
ins I specifically asked a question
probably three or four times but I I
didn't get an answer about there being
an interest for sale I know somebody
very close to me very I spent a lot of
time with this person that would be very
interested in buying it but I I wish him
nothing but the best with with the
purchase that was made yeah that was
that was an interesting there's gonna
have to be some off the air combo dinner
or something eventually and talk about
it because that's uh I'm surprised yes
at some point in time I know that the
rumblings around the industry was to
have you be a part of our industry as
some you know and some advisor or
something like that yeah I mean you know
how I feel about the business you know
how I feel about the industry you know
how I feel and how much respect I have
for people like you because most people
see body building and they say oh you
know you just got to go out there and do
this and I could go out there winless
troll Olympian or wall always remind
you know that one time where the lady
said I would never want my husband to
look like you and he said don't worry he
never will you know it's not like
there's something where anybody can wake
up in a day in for seven straight years
become a seven times stroll impe are you
kidding me that's not an easy feat to do
that with personal challenges with
health with injuries which sickness wit
flus with all this other stuff and you
were trying to keep your life together
so you know I got a lot of love for the
game but I understand that yeah so as
Dan Salomon reached out are you guys on
speaking terms
oh yeah for sure I mean I'm going into
the Olympia last year he started we
started texting I want to say around May
of last year so we we had dialogue and
he was given me perspective as to what
they were doing because I always feel
like when you're friends with someone or
at least when you're really good
acquaintances with somebody you should
give them constructive criticism because
you want things to be better and your
friend should push you right so I did I
was like hey you know I really feel like
you should be doing this with your
marketing you should doing this and he's
like slow down you need to think about
this one like no I've been around like
I've seen this fail I've seen this work
and we had that dialogue which was
really good and then leading up into the
Olympia I think he started seeing
content come out of me in the gym
training and he was like hitting me up
like dude like you're doing the Olympia
and I'm like no I'm not doing it would
be like no you definitely look like
you're doing the show I just saw her
you're in Europe you're over here
training which shirt off like this looks
great
less talk and I'm like no I'm not doing
a show but then after the show happened
you know I just told him I said hey
there's there's nothing like as far as
like a an issue or bitterness or
anything toward you or anyone really and
it's always good to me to have those you
know those open transparent combos
because the internet as you know
the fake news will come out and people
will make up their own narrative and
they do it obviously for their own
personal benefit to get their views up
and the comments and engagement but um
yeah I don't have any issue with them
and out and I was actually happy for him
as well because he's been in the sport
for a long time you can tell he loves
the game that's one thing you know when
we had dinner together you can tell he
loves the game and I just hope you can't
say this but I can say this I hope they
take care of their seven-time Champions
I hope they take care of their winners I
hope they take care of the people that
are the faces of mr. Olympia and
bodybuilding I hope they do that I think
if they do that it's gonna be big you
know a lot of times it's easy for I just
had a meeting this morning with our
staff we had a staff meeting today and
we're zooming because we have a 80% of
our employees working from home 20% out
of the home office and I had a meeting
and every single time we have this
meeting I remind them don't forget we
have this insurance company that's
growing and doing well because there are
14,000 agents that are selling a policy
to somebody out there while you have a
job here so in the world of bodybuilding
you know the brand exist because there's
bodybuilders out there that are training
tirelessly diet all the stuff they got
to put their bodies through without
those bodybuilders there is no brand so
they got to remember who the talent is I
hope he continues doing that so look
question everyone's asking me their same
Pat rumor has it in the streets you're
good friends with Phil Heath I said
first of all let's you say this a rumor
would get friends what's wrong with that
rumor there there's nothing wrong with
being friends with Phil Heath yeah Phil
Heath and I have a relationship together
but Phil are you going to compete in the
stroll MP or athletic on well right now
we can't even really get into the gym
right now stubble you know I I
definitely feel like those are two
events that sparked a lot of interest um
you know I've never competed athletic on
I do know that it would be their
inaugural season so once they make their
announcement sir
whatever along with the Olympia I think
for me it's more like how do i align
life in itself with business and
obviously my personal life and then the
desire to want to compete again because
I got a taste of not doing it and there
was parts of it that I liked there's
parts of it that I didn't like so I
think a better answer would come when we
get through this phase one you know and
be back into business and and kind of
see like okay maybe I get on the phone
with dad maybe I get on the phone with
Jake you know I talked it over when I
manager Danny Garcia and the team or at
EDC and we kind of figure out because
Pat I was standing on your doorstep
and I told you what I wanted to do I was
like I'm not eating I'm gonna do TV and
film I want to be a Hollywood star I
want to be the next deep Dwayne Johnson
yep I'm gonna do all that stuff and
you're like Phil compete like you're the
legend this Matt but I feel like that
part of last year we started the process
of transitioning away and that takes a
lot of time and effort but with
Hollywood not filming right now and with
bodybuilding shows not happening right
now it's kind of like at a standstill so
you kind of have a time to not relax but
to kind of look around so okay Voice
coaches acting coaches like can we do
stuff right now okay no you can't you
need to physically seen it okay all
right Jim there's no gym okay there's no
show what but once all that start stuff
kind of calms down I feel like
everything is going to kind of merge and
kind of figure it out so and then once
that happens I feel like a decision has
to be made I will not I will do this I
will not leave the fans hanging that's
for sure when there's a time where I can
make a decision I'm gonna say yes or I'm
gonna say no I'm not gonna drag it out
you know because I don't think that's
okay because no one likes holdouts from
athletes with contracts they definitely
ain't gonna like it with a seven-time
champ
yeah I remember that conversation you
and I had we were
the house I don't even know what time it
was true o'clock in the morning you over
was waiting for 45 minutes you kept
telling him run the mic or guys do you
want me to leave feels like no I just
start the mind I'm like we don't get to
hang out my son like man he can come
back but you know so for me it was more
the love of the game because you never
want to see a guy leave that's got five
more years you realistically you could
be a first double-digit mr. Olympia
champion but I also understand by the
way I posted a comment writing I'm
cursing on what you guys are saying
maybe he's gonna take your counsel
should bill he'd compete in athletic on
or mr. Olympia comment below I'm sure
he's gonna get a chance to watch some of
the comments should he compete in
Mistral India and go for eight times
time Lee Haney and Ronnie and maybe
going for nine times first ever or
should he just say look man I'm gonna go
pursue Danny Garcia Dwayne Johnson
Hollywood I got the looks I got the eyes
I've got a physique I can go out there
and run a bunch of movies get paid
millions of dollars and not just for a
few hundred thousand dollars comment
below tell us which one you're thinking
he should go for and keep inviting these
mr. Olympia talents the bodybuilders so
on here to listen as well but you know
for me the the the question I have is
say if coronavirus wasn't going on and
this shut that wasn't going on say
wasn't going on
were you getting ready to compete like
were you cuz you're you know you know
it's pretty obvious to kind of see you
can only hide so much you look legit you
know what I'm saying you look really
good like were you kind of planning on
saying I'm gonna be ready if I go this
way and compete athletic on I'm ready
for that if I go mr. Olympia I'm ready
for are you kinda in that state right
now I going into this year well let me
backtrack so in December I turned 40 and
I was literally I remember I was like
you know what I want to write down some
goals and this and that and I was like
hmm not trying to take the quote last
dance but like one more ride and I was
like questioning marking my foot in my
notepads like one more ride now it's
like if you if you could only do it one
time like would you do it one time you
know like because that's maybe all you'd
be offered because of the other
endeavors that I'd have and I was like
wow I would entertain and I just have to
make sure that the scheduling the you
know everything will have to be in
alignment because I have functioned out
of chaos many times getting ready for
the Olympia and it's not always fun and
I thought well if I had a chance to make
it work
for myself because I'm the one that has
to go into gym I'm the one who has to do
all that stuff have I ever had it like
where it was kind of perfect or damn
near close like with business with
relationship this you know with
everything I was like well if everything
came together I mean it's kind of like a
no-brainer cuz it's less stress why
wouldn't you but here we are
2020 getting our asses kicked you know
so but yeah leading into the show I mean
into this year you know at the beginning
of the year I was like wow like this
would be kind of cool you know this kind
of kicked the tires around let's see
what my weight could get up to because I
didn't really push it hard last year's
like let me see you know what my my PRS
would be as far as I you know strength
is concerned because if I can get to a
certain level I'm not going to expect my
my muscles to look a certain way and the
last thing you want to do is be a shell
of yourself of yourself getting ready
for a contest like that because let's
face it everybody else is still climbing
a mountain for me it's like a legacy and
you don't want to tarnish it because
you're not ready and but yeah that was
that was really my mindset and you know
I almost hit you up I think I text you
to say like man I was really before all
this happened I was kind of leaning
toward you know talking to Danny about
like maybe that could be a possibility
it was more like maybe like nah not like
last year where was like kind of like
hell no it was more like well what would
that look like
because being away from the state
so you know only do one show a year so
that's a long time for me to not be on a
stage so you're like what is that
and then now writing down like what does
that mean to you
you know who's involved who's gonna help
you just crossing off things and I was
just like well there's not enough boxes
being checked off at the moment but who
knows like I said I mean you know I
would I would hope that if things could
online like I would I would do one more
because I'm because I would love to you
know give the fans something at least
one more time at least one but like I
said I mean if Hollywood called me up
tomorrow and that's the hard part
right there probably would say hey Phil
we got you new action film this and that
the other it's gonna require you to be
on set for six seven months or you can
go through the Olympia that you've
already won which one you're gonna
choose I'm like well I was already
transitioning away so I choose the film
but you know if there was a way to do
both you know I'd have to just because
we all want the best of everything so
you know I think I'm I'm personally I
feel like I deserved that because I've
done the work absolutely yeah seven
years are um you you you choose you know
you choose but also at the same time
Michael Jordan went to Jerry and said 36
million they said yes I also hold
whoever gets you the brand realizes that
hey what's in it for me right now
how many more magazine covers are you
really looking for at this point of the
game you don't care about magazine
covers so I hope they're realizing that
as well because you go do a movie you
get to three million AutoCheck the
winnings for mr. Olympia right now is
what 400 450 some number like that yeah
and it's not bad at you know and I know
a lot of fans was like well it's not
about the money in this Ananas it's not
necessarily about that it is about but
it's a part of it it's not just one of
it it's about it's about the legacy and
this and that's about the opportunity to
do that but there's opportunity costs
that goes into that as well
and we've talked about that before you
know you got to be able to pay for stuff
everything ain't free food isn't free
massage therapy ain't free chiropractic
acupuncture ain't free none of this
stuff is free to like oh you're mr.
Limpy you get sponsorship to be honest
like none of those services I just
mentioned I get for free because I deal
with people that I also respect and I
will pay them for their service and I've
always really done that because I just
never liked Owen people stuff you know
and I and I want and I want them to
respect you know their own craft and say
hey look like you know some people want
to bargain so hey if you if you do the
shoutout for me in this nap that's one
thing but if I call you up in the middle
of the night and say hey man like my
back just went out and I need you over
here at 6:00 in the morning you're gonna
be like hell no so you got to come in at
9:00 and it's not with my kids I'm not
gonna wake up my wife and kids and for
you but if I'm paying you and I'm paying
you well you're gonna do it you know you
just are so I understand if I want to be
paid then I have to reciprocate and I
have to pay for that service so it does
cost and you can ask any pro bodybuilder
this it costs money to compete of course
we will it cost a lot so like anyone
that isn't sponsored is you know it's
it's more difficult you know but but I
would say that a lot of us are very
blessed
especially now like any pro athlete let
alone a pro bodybuilder men and women
right now that is sponsored during this
you better be calling up that sponsor
and thanking them every chance you get
and every chance you getting you better
be posted when it's time to post you
better be on it because when it's time
for you to compete they're the ones that
help you do what you do for those fans
you know and and you know I'm not
sponsored like that I used to be but if
I was sponsored like I was back in the
Danny oh my gosh like it's not just
holding up a bottle and saying hey take
this it's more like telling your story
and then reminding people why they're
you know like you know I just think
right now
sensing like a different form of
gratitude to what I do have during this
this time I don't you know what Pat I
was going to ask you like do you call
this a crisis or do you call it just a
certain time in our life that we're
dealing with a pandemic
now this 100% crisis I mean there's no
question about it it's a crisis and it's
I mean you're talking about
26 and a half million unemployment we're
about to get to 40 million unemployment
trillions of dollars of investors monies
lost I'm talking investment bankers in
their world they're sitting around
trying to do deals and deals are not out
there they are but it's not the same
deals that they want and the buyers are
little worried it's it's everybody's
being hit in a different way and I
actually don't like to approach they're
taken right now but that's a complete
different conversation you know I you
know best thing I heard the other day
was this people call me and they say Pat
it's irresponsible what you're doing why
are you going to the office every day
we're being told to stay home
non-essential why are you at work I said
you know lady one time gave me the best
advice she said you know what's the
closest thing a man will ever experience
to having kids and giving birth to a
baby I said what says I've given birth
to three kids she's telling me this she
says but I also started a company and
when I started a company it was very
painful I put my life savings into it we
almost went out of business sleepless
nights anxiety attack panic attacks that
almost cost my marriage the closest pain
I've ever experienced to having a kid is
starting a business and that moment when
she said that just like I want to be
very protective of my kids I'm also too
being protective of the business that I
put my lifeblood into that I have to be
protective of it so it is I mean I think
putting it that way I would love to see
someone try to refute that because the
way you illustrate that cuz I think of
that I mean I just started this
supplement company last year and it's
like I can only imagine being I mean I
put all my savings into this there is
someone asking you know they hey could
you give me money for my church at this
time my honest
they do like it ain't gonna be much like
I used to like it's it's all tied into
these things so I can only imagine being
a founder five ten years from now it
grows and then I'm faced with these
challenges and then being told not to
work it's like I've seen the videos that
I'm I'm literally at the beginning of
those videos where it's like yeah here
you're literally in your car like almost
in tears like what am I to do and this
met and there ain't no problem with that
the problem is it's like do you give up
and the answer is no you don't give up
on your dream I can't allow someone to
make me give up on life because that's
not worth living it's just not and
expecting a handout and props to you for
not taking the bailout money you know
creating that and that cuz that told me
something I was like wow like if I do
this right I will have nest eggs here in
these buckets here so that if this
happens I'm good if this happens I'm
good and then not just me it's not just
about me and my family it's about the
other employees their families because
who wants to get on the phone call it's
one thing to have to let someone go on
fire and you know for lack of
performance of just we're going a
different direction but it's another
thing like when it ain't their fault
that's tough that's the conversation no
person wants to have right now like what
bedside manner just like what
instruction manual does 1/2 you know
I've already read patty McCoy's book on
how do you do that and it's it's
something I think everybody has a
different answer for it is a it is
definitely weird times but again the
other part is I don't know why no matter
what it is you we need times like this
you know the whole story about forest
fire I don't know how the whole story
wood forest fire if it's not a man-made
forest fire
you know forest fires are necessary for
the forest now why are forest fires
necessary for the forests here's why
there's this debate going on right now
whether the government needs to
constantly be allowed these too big to
fail companies right it's like Oh
we got to be careful with these
too-big-to-fail we can't let them go out
of business it's not a good thing we
can't let them go out of business but
also at the same time sometimes you got
to let those big companies go out of
business because in the forest when a
fire takes place and these trees have
been hogging Sun for years now they open
up because if you ever going for us
you're walking you don't get any
sunlight it's very dark
once those trees go all of a sudden
within two days everything is green now
you're seeing small little plants coming
up next trees coming up this is a way to
replenish and give birth to the next
small business owner that's going to
come up and compete so I'm actually
curious to know what's gonna happen next
it's a total reset I mean there was a
article the other day in USA Today
discussing meat packing companies like
Jade yes and a couple other ones talking
about I believe there was like 2000
corona virus you know people that got I
don't know if they're asymptomatic or
whatever the two thousand in this man
these are people you know Justin all
this stuff working shoulder-to-shoulder
you know cutting up meat miss nap and it
was you know the way I read it was to
enforce fear on people like oh yeah now
your food supply is going to be messed
up and also stuff I don't know if you
heard of this but of course but um you
know one of my chiropractor buddies I go
see here in Denver his family's been
ranching ranching since late 1800s he
created a company called mile-high meets
right he had me come on he was like hey
I want you to be ambassador for this cuz
you know I'll sing you some cuts of beef
and I was like oh this is cool let me
try did it last year I was like wow this
is really good this snap really
cost-effective so we've been in business
together right he sends it to he says me
this article yesterday I read I go sucks
for them because it's gonna help out
this small guy so this goes to show like
what you said it's like yeah it's gonna
hurt these larger corporations that mean
that may not be able to pivot as far as
like their their supply to
is concerned like you ain't gonna lay
off all those people you still need to
cut you know cattle and you know you
need to do all that stuff but for the
small guy I guess we don't have that
problem
we can do the distancing we can do all
that and we don't have to supply the
world we only need to supply it maybe
five states you know or 50 just with
shipping out our product but it's just a
little different so yeah you're right I
looked at that issue and I love the
analogy like what the trees because ya
know those big ones and the meat
companies if they went away we would be
like overnight you don't rock and roll
59 million Americans have a job due to
small business owners companies with
less than 500 employees I think you're
gonna see a wave of small business
owners coming up in the next 5-10 years
that's what I foresee happening Phil
question have you been watching any of
the bodybuilding interviews the most
recent ones the back and forth between
Shawn ray and Dex
I gotta go they're the ones between
Shauna and Dexter have you watched that
back and forth I know you're a big
popcorn guy bro if I had stock in over
Redenbacher right now I obviously I have
privileged information from both people
the one thing I will say is is that I
did ask Dexter who started this and then
he showed me the receipts and I said
well you can't say certain things so
many times and not get your hand slapped
I'm gonna probably slapped the hand he
slit the throat you know he went he went
there but you know as far as like the
competitions and stuff
I don't think amongst the pros we all
have dexter higher than chunk all of us
because he won the Olympia he won the
Arnold Classic when the Masters Olympia
it's on all that stuff so when you think
about Ennis and it's something to seem
like okay you're hall-of-famer listen
that Shawn but you know your claim
fame is that you you were top five in
the only bid 12 straight years but
Dexter has also won more shows than you
so like which one would you read which
career would you rather have so I think
as far as static and certain Dexter wins
that head-to-head it always sucks with
this especially in sports and we all do
this you know it's Jordan but still the
bestest goat James coming up you know
this and that is you know I get the
comparisons with me and Ronnie Coleman
Allah who's the real goat and it's like
whoa I never compete against Ronnie
unfortunately and I would say that so
fortunately for Shaun he will never know
like how he would stack against Dexter
Jackson who I saw in 2008 when he won
the Olympia because that that physique
when he beat Jay he beat the masked guy
you know Shaun never beat the masked guy
so you know it's it's up for debate but
I think those two definitely they either
need to go out for a drink and you know
the main and just get it all out and hug
you kiss or now that we can't shake I
don't know or just really never speaking
to just don't keep each other's name in
each other's mouths again because the
last thing you want is to have it
escalate you know one of the things I've
always tried to make sure we do is not
go at each other too hard in front of
the general public because they don't
know us you know they know they don't
know like the fans don't know us like
that so I would prefer like if we were
to go back and forth that we were
actually in in front of each other so
then it's funny you know then it's like
everybody can see like a round table
you're just going back and forth but
when you do a video and then I do the
receipts of it I do a video like what's
the main goal here is there a suggestion
there are you making a suggestion I mean
here's here's here's what I think would
be interesting here's what I think would
be interesting what I think would be
interesting times like this is if we
have Dexter and Shawn they're together
and Dexter brings an ally and Shawn
brings an ally so Dexter can say I'm
gonna bring Cormier you know and Shawn's
gonna say I'm gonna bring whoever Shawn
wants to bring okay and then we do a
dialogue and we open it up and
bodybuilders can come and ask questions
and then they can talk because I talk to
both of them off the record and they're
not as bad to each other as it came out
on but you you know what it'd be
interesting to see these guys talk to
one another by the way just so you know
our buddy flex it joined us yeah and
flex I'm gonna quote what flex said when
you said he was top 5 for 12 consecutive
mr. Olympius he says so basically he was
a loser 12 years in a row yeah no
exactly I mean you know you want to keep
things kind of lazy about it and stuff
you're right
like I don't know if I would have
because when I was coming up I thought
of that as an accomplishment as well
because of his size differential the
difference of size and in different eras
he went you know he was around you know
when you know Dorian and you know he
knows like these different competitors
he'd be a lot of amazing guys too but I
think what sucks is when you've competed
and you didn't beat a person at their
all-time best or like really close to it
because that's how I feel like when you
can say yeah you beat someone did you
beat him just one time or did you just
own them you know did you own them
because I'm sure you know someone could
you know like if I lost in somebody my
whole thing was could you do it over and
over again not let me know like man you
just got my number and then sports that
just happens so yeah I think that would
be really interesting but I all I can
say is that I I will agree with you I
know that there's not as much animosity
as people to want to think because it's
very easy in our industry for us to get
the drama and like they just want to
find us that's like
you name the time when you ever seen two
bodybuilders fight never so it's only
gonna just be a you know King Kong back
and forth but it would be very
interesting to see well I mean I'll put
it out there and we'll see if anybody's
gonna want to pull up and do it so guys
if you know death so you know you know
Shawn wants you tag them let them see
this part and they know how to get a
hold of me and if they want to do it we
can accommodate it and matter of fact
you know what we could do we can have it
sponsored by a popcorn company and we
can take the funds buy popcorn company
and share it with Sean and Dex and say
this interview is sponsored by give me a
big popcorn any one of them so that's a
thought I'll read some of the comments
and some people just basically saying
like Sean seemed kind of bitter and this
and that and you know what I haven't say
well I would be too if I was in his
situation it's not the throw Shaitaan is
just that yeah never one like [ __ ] like
you would always you know like but I
think some that picked that picture
right there I love this one because of
the fact that pair banal definitely shot
that and it's black and white and I
never and I'm jealous because I never
got a chance to do a photo shoot where I
knew that everything was with the white
background and the black and white
because that right there is incredible
it is incredible I would say this though
Pat Sean ray is easily the [ __ ] and
that's like and I beat this guy many
times but that pose dude that's nasty it
is that is just nasty bro and I in a
what's beautiful about his life that I
didn't get a chance to say an extra shot
but I stood next to Dexter I did my
first one or class
in 2007 I please v and I remember that
call yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna be up
there with the big guys you know I've
ever seen - you're backstage and I was
like this ain't my night now and I was
you know I was a rookie at that show and
it does take you to lose to someone like
a seasoned veteran for you to respect
them at a higher level but but yeah
those pictures man who ever shot that I
believe that's a pair of a now shop
because it's the black and white I
believe that was for muscular
development that's a sag freaking
photograph man and that's the beauty of
our sport man is that you get these
photographers that can just capture
these moments that that's you couldn't
even ask someone to draw that that's
like Marvel or DC comic like go ahead
and draw this it's like I don't even
know what but that's masterpiece and I
think that's why we train so hard you
know so so in your eyes you got decks
ahead of Sean and your eyes Dex is a
shot okay I I do because of also who he
be is more about who he be take me out
of it like it's more about who he's
stood next to because this for evolves
like eras of bodybuilding are different
you know and what they judged on was
just different so it I I definitely have
I got another picture I got a show
filled and I'm gonna see a reaction I
just want you to react when you see this
one dude like what's crazy about this
one is that if you look at the roundness
like it's just cartoonish right crazy
it's just the cartoonish doubts on flex
from you they're the man it's gorgeous
it's amazing and it's the the set the
deep cuts in those claws people don't
have that people where it starts all the
way at the hip mm-hmm people don't have
that yet here yes
like where his hip starts yeah all the
way down that that's that's what we call
three-dimensional muscle because of
operation and a lot of guys don't have
that and I don't know I don't know how
you I'm seven-time mission I've been I'm
telling everybody like I don't even know
how you trained for that I think that
there's certain things that your
god-given and that you apply yourself to
get that separation in detail and
roundness there's one thing to be super
like ripped up and gifted all the
striations and that's great but it's
another thing to have that deep
separation whew so Phil here's what we
got
here's what we got so right now we got
flex lewis on you just joined us we got
KY green on he just joined us we got
flex wheeler on we got you on and we
obviously have some paparazzi in the mr.
Olympia world that's on we got some on
so flex Lewis gentlemen flex and I have
spoken before
kai green who Congrats on your movie men
on being on the what you did you crushed
it and flex wheeler if you can tell your
buddies because I'm trying to make a
pitch here I'd like to pitch something I
would like to be a promoter for a
bodybuilding thing here and see if I can
pull this off so Phil is it okay if I
dream is it okay if I dream Martin
Luther King said I have a dream is it
okay for Middle Eastern has a dream and
a Syrian Armenian has a dream is that
okay okay so by the way Kai green says
I'm Phil's biggest haters so here's my
dream here's what I'd like to see tell
you and flex Lewis flex wheeler Kai tag
your peers I have a dream and I hope
dance Solomon sees this as well because
this actually benefits him and Jake
would benefits in as well this is my
dream what if what is this is a what if
Mario I'm just doing what if what if say
this thing slows down and goes away and
what if Dan Jake would they can
rearrange the contract with the hotel
and get the day to October let's just
say move it back
in September to give you guys a little
bit more time to train to October let's
say late October Halloween time so
people can go to Vegas go to the show
see it what is we do mr. Olympia and at
this mr. Olympia Phil Heath makes a
comeback Kai Green comes back what if
all of these guys you talking obviously
Curry's gonna be there what if we get
Dexter to do one more for the hell of it
what if we get everybody to show up and
everyone from the past is there to enjoy
this show and we witness craziness and
this becomes an insane sellout event
hopefully by then people are a little
bit more calm now obviously solomon jake
would those guys gonna have to have the
masks and everything on but I can only
imagine if you guys are lined up on
stage and feel your theory guy comes
back and maybe takes a year break from
being an actor in Hollywood he still
looks good but if God wanted to get back
into it he could do it what if that
happens now how do you think the fans
would like to see that you think that
would make it a little bit exciting well
absolutely I was just reading up what
Cairo he said the kind yeah he said only
a magic eye until nobody else I think
well first of all I mean every fan in
the world knows that Kai and I have had
one of the most intense robberies we've
ever seen on stage but the list of all
those guys I mean yeah of course I mean
people would my take is no question
about it I mean that's it would
definitely be a large event I'm sure in
it I'm sure of it what is flex wheeler
said he said I have a dream oh he just
really said I don't think it would be
enough time too many people lost money
due to the crisis nor do I think it's
enough time for athletes to be at their
best
hmm-what but Phil that's a part where
you said mature muscle we're gonna see
who really has mature months
right right right well you know I'm sure
the people that are watching obviously
the people in the industry are watching
I'm sure they've already thought about
these things too you know at the end of
the day it's their business you know and
and like you said I mean athletes have
to you know essentially prepare and be
ready no matter what what is Chi talking
about Chi said don't worry flex I'm
always on my best by the way I didn't
know I was this good of a [ __ ] talker
he's only got that decent because of me
he knows that he took your class he took
a course on [ __ ] talking with Philly I
got it it's pretty impressive but by the
way you know since flex Wheeler said I
don't think they could pull it off
here's another creative idea that mr.
Olympia could pull off to keep it
healthy look many people around the
world pay fights to watch pay-per-view
and they watch MMA pay-per-view they
watch a lot of different thing
pay-per-view what if Solomon and mr.
Olympia came back and said if you want
to see a live bodybuilding show yet we
still do social distancing if we get a
hundred thousand people that pay $99 for
pay-per-view or $69 whatever it could be
will host the events and if we get a
hundred thousand people that pay $69 or
$99 and fail hi everybody promotes it
they also increase the purse and double
it what if they do something like that
so instead of winning $400,000 now
you're fighting for $800,000 again I'm
just being creative I just said I have a
dream I didn't say it's gonna become a
reality it's just a dream yeah you know
your thing you're transitioning then to
like they call it at the the
pay-per-view buys and stuff like that
you know darn well yeah I already knew
it since what 1 million people paid me
him Phil guy really wants to get it on
but he you know that he wants but yeah I
mean like
I guess that part is unprecedented as
far as like you know like what they did
like within an a and you know the with
the screwed how about a crazier idea how
about even a crazy idea film how about a
crazier idea how about if I put a
million bucks on the line okay hear me
out no no hear me out wait a minute hear
me up I put a million bucks on the line
for first place and I put $300,000
second place hypothetically but a
million dollars for first place and it's
pay-per-view driven if we can drive a
certain downloads of pay-per-view
I'll make the person million bucks and I
by the way I would even do it in a way
where we can make it even bigger I would
take a certain profit margin off the top
but I would even pass it to everybody
else and we'd sign a contract up front
and if mr. Olympia didn't want to do it
maybe we would just make a million
dollars during pandemic times I think it
could be an opportunity this is when you
gotta be opportunistic you know it's
just again it's just an idea so Kai just
told me right now kai said the Tony
Soprano call he said he wants his [ __ ]
back I like guy already what do you say
he said deposit that checking my bank
accounts he seems pretty confident I'm
the last time yeah I don't I mean look I
haven't been there I'm just the YouTuber
you know I'm just a business guy I don't
know what's going on here so I'm the
innocent guy someone will hand me a
drink but Phil do you think people would
think about that if the purse was a
million bucks oh I mean I definitely
believe that I know they had tried
pay-per-view one time and I think Dan
would know more about that part because
I think that was around the time that he
was doing pro bodybuilding weekly but
obviously media has changed her mad
since then I do believe that you just
threw a freaking curveball to a lot of
people right now that you just made this
video go I don't care how many people
are currently watching is going to
happen like after people going to be
talking about this my phone's probably
gonna be ringing like what the hell like
go get go have Patrick give me the
million dollars like go get that million
but I definitely believe that people
would have a greater sense of urgency if
they knew that there was a bag that big
because that's a different type of bag
that ain't for me thousand on the bag
that's missing really not a bag that's
crazy how big is the body building war
world fans meaning how many fans who's
genuinely followed the mr. Olympia brand
how many are there that actually attend
events well you know I would say around
that eight to ten thousand I know it's
been around like you know like since I
started you know around that eight
thousand no say ten thousand they would
know better numbers and I would but I
would I would generally say to actually
witness the show let's just say 7,500
people for the flesh we're saying you
would do a computer so expose to no
would you compete of pep put up the
million bucks for first place yeah but
but as far as the total people that go
to Vegas for that particular event I
mean it's I would assume that it has to
be at least fifty seventy-five thousand
or you know I mean a lot of people in
the expo so I mean you can't go anywhere
I know for me like I have to stay off
site because I would bump in the massive
amounts of people in Vegas that are
there for the Olympia if I would have
been walking around that week so and by
the way this would you would still
follow social distancing guidelines
right because what we would do is
imagine if we did this and we picked the
SiC hotel we don't even do it in Vegas
we pick the a state that's fairly
healthy so we're not gonna do New York
we're not gonna do Connecticut we're not
gonna do places that have a lot of cases
we picked the most incredible resort
incredible resort maybe we do it in
West Palm Beach down the street from our
La Grange where the hotel is where's the
hotel tell me the hotel that I like
breakers breakers which is right across
the street from Flagler's we do not
breakers and we put the competitors in
the Suites nice breakers is where every
president has gone and had dinner
breakers is where billionaires go to
breakers is an incredible place so we
did it up breakers and then the judges
we bring judges in a way where all the
body builders are comfortable with the
judges we bring so it's fair and then we
tee it up I don't know it's it's
definitely creative ID if you're telling
me 75,000 we would almost feel like a
gofundme matter of fact let me tell you
this is getting pretty real right now
because hear me out fill hear me out
here if I put a GoFundMe out there and I
put a number and I say if this many
people subscribe to it at a $99 price I
will put half of it into the tournament
so for instance let's do the number
let's see if we get a hundred thousand
people that pay a hundred bucks how much
is that - ten million if a hundred
thousand people pay a hundred bucks
that's ten million what if we put half
of it into the tournament and then we
get the place fill this is getting
interesting to me yeah but you gotta you
know that's when you gotta go talk to
mr. Jake woo why would I need to though
what why would I talk to Jake wood
though number what if I don't call it
mr. Olympia oh well then you would have
to get a sanction through the Federation
I would need to get it sanctioned by the
Federation how much politics is there
with that
[Music]
dude I'm just trying to figure out a way
to get a million dollars in your pocket
man I'm trying to get a million dollar
cheque is what I'm trying to do now you
know it's funny there was a time where I
thought and hold on tight I got one for
you I think I told Kai this but I said
you know could you imagine if Kai and I
did like remember when they did like
that what was it the race between Ben
Johnson not Ben Johnson but Donovan
Bailey and Michael Johnson
I remember that 150 Canadian with it he
pulled and it was you know supposed to
be for a certain amount of money in this
man and I was like huh could you imagine
if they did something like that would
just cry and myself because you know
really needing you know like something
like that but it's just you know I was I
admitted it to Kai because I was like
you know he and I were talking about at
one point time doing some type of a film
or something that lead to you know but
but you can't promote it you need a
promoter behind it
you need a promoter behind it with a big
mouth you need a promoter behind it that
you need a you need a real thumb King to
do that you need a real account Kings
the bikes you know said it's a lot of
politics but you know at the same time I
mean you know you would definitely want
there to be there's my the industry with
with the Federation of so I would my
only thing is that if I was to do if I
was to do another show it would make
sense for me to do an Olympian because
you know you know I don't know because
that's the biggest show right well then
maybe I don't know but maybe but maybe
but tears here's my thing like so then
why don't you think the dam wanted you
to buy it
I have no idea Mario was sitting right
there and I said hey cuz that was really
interesting for me like I'm having a
hard time you ought to ask him you ought
to ask him it's like well you know not
really the company is doing really well
but if you want to maybe put in
something and sign the NDA I'm like I
said what's the top line what's the
numbers look like what's the value of
somebody
to buy it and I'm asking a buying
question no no bite no follow up let me
put you know but you know it is what it
is maybe it was a message from the man
upstairs saying you don't want to buy
mr. Olympia right now don't know oh you
know I don't even want to get more
trouble than a poverty entire probably
like my entire world probably gotten
kicked out of my house even having this
conversation
feel right seriously listen I'm just
trying to raise money and I'm saying
what if you ever seen a movie warrior
with Tom Hardy oh my gosh Phil you gotta
watch a sick movie first of all sick
movie Nick Nolte's in it he kills it
what is the other guy's name who's in it
the brother he's a great actor he's in
it so what this guy does is he's a he's
a rich guy that says he's putting five
million dollar on the line to find out
who's the baddest man on the planet one
fight and it's elimination and the two
brothers go up and they face each other
in the championship it's a sick movie so
all I'm saying is the baddest
bodybuilder in the world
I don't know I don't know you know my
whole thing is you know and this is just
being honest like I'm a part of the
Federation that has been very very good
to me and I would not want to do another
show outside of that I really believe in
that because that's how I build my
legacy
you know I've built my legacy being mr.
Olympia but my legacy through the NPC am
I getting you in trouble Phil no I mean
like they know they know where my heart
is they know and they should know so
he's good they should all know work I'm
being serious right now the NPC they
should know where my heart is I've
always been loyal to them they've done a
great job you know and even when even
when things that I may not agreed with
like you know me losing a month year I
mean it was
it wasn't something like out of
something weird with them it was just a
decision that they made but they always
and I'll give Jim angle a lot of credit
he's always managed to finger the
athletes first and he's always managed
to reach out to me in various areas but
you know and I'll say like the prize
money has always gone up you know with
the Olympia has always been a little bit
better
I do think like with dancehall I'm still
wondering why he didn't further pursue
that but that's a whole nother
conversation but I don't think that this
conversation should make them think and
I would hope that they wouldn't think
anything weird because we're just
talking but they should know where my
sentiment is this is this is you and
this is probably why they don't like me
talking to us because but friends do
this friends do you know we speculate
and you did ask me can you dream and a
lot of people are going to now have
conversation about it but in all
seriousness I mean it's all to better
sport that you and I both love and it
wasn't it's not the tear anything down
is to actually bring it up so Kai's
saying you should see my DMS Ville
people already DM in him feel that this
is what I would say to the Federation
that's watching this if you have a guy
like Phil who just said what he said the
last two minutes I would do whatever I
could to take care of this man if you
just heard what he just said I'd lock
him up is what I'd be doing whatever
that means life time whatever okay
because I'd love to have another guy
winning eight times Phil you know I run
businesses for a living if I had it my
way you have no idea how bad I'd love to
run a frickin contest and shock the hell
out of the world and take care of the
bodybuilders in a way where they would
tell every other bodybuilder when that
crazy Armenian Assyrian guy puts an
event together you go to it because this
guy knows how to take care of the talent
but I don't know man I may go to sleep
tonight and wake up with some weird
dreams in the middle of the night and I
may just text you and say Phil we're
doing
and I'm gonna go call them up and see
what I could do you're gonna wake up
with a bunch of emails that's what you
gonna wake up with but how about at some
point hmm
would you ever explore doing a show with
me
what are you competing Yuki you're not
competing in it no I want to put a show
where a guy who is fighting for the
greatest of all time is in it that's
what I'm interested in
see here's what I'm interested in I'm
interested in something that's never
been done before
I'm not intrude I want out there now
what I'm saying to you is I'm not saying
anything about I'll support your event
whatever way you want me to support you
you know how I feel about you I'm a true
believer so I'm a I'm a you know you can
call me two o'clock in the morning you
farm up I'm picking up that call we have
a different kind of a relationship
together you know that I know that but
I'm talking about if the industry wants
to use luck I'll give you some stats
here here's some stats freeze okay
here's some stats for you
q1 q1 Netflix gained 15 million new
subscribers q1 a hundred and eight you
saw that tweet a hundred and eighty
three million global customers 83
million people watched at one movie what
is it called with Mark Wahlberg in it I
don't know the name of it 65 million
watch the Spanish speaking show della
paper whatever something paper they're
like and then 64 million people watched
Tiger King its content time I could get
a hundred thousand eyeballs and I can
get the bodybuilders a fat check and
that I know I could do but it has to be
something that's never been done before
and we take it you know we take care of
the bodybuilders in a crazy way but
again listen Phil I have a record of my
career of shaking things up and it
always ends up favoring the talent so
this is good news for all the
competitors because in no way in the
world
these Federation's are gonna give me the
license politically ain't no way in the
world that's gonna happen because they
wouldn't want that to take place but
again going back to it I'm really
curious to know what mr. Olympia is
gonna do here and how they're gonna
pivot yeah I think they're gonna do a
great I think they're gonna do I think
every promoter right I'm just gonna say
it I got think every promoter right now
they have no choice but to swim they
have no choice because they don't want
to sink because you mentioned something
earlier about you know the the business
being your baby this is their baby every
promoter I know they own something the
stores or gyms or all of it in between
and you know I really think that they're
going to be taken advantage of this time
because they're competitive promoters as
well they know that like maybe they're
there come their competition in their
own state or their neighboring state
isn't doing so hot and they're gonna say
hey I want to take over those shows so I
really believe that we're gonna see just
like with all sports right now I think
the strongest are gonna survive but it's
gonna make everything ten times better
it's not going to go backwards when
everything gets opened up again you know
I really see it being a lot better for
promoters and athletes because if you
come out of this whole crisis worse you
didn't do anything right in the time
that you had you did green I mean you
sat on your ass you didn't you didn't
like you say you didn't you didn't
sharpen up those weaknesses creative
make them into strengths you didn't find
out where your your blind spots are as
you mentioned and I am more confident
with the guys that I've talked to the
promoters that I know that like I said
that their backs are against the wall
and they know like they're out swinging
that once this gets reopened so I'm very
happy for them but I'm most importantly
happy for the athletes that are gonna
get a chance to compete because I know a
lot of shows got postponed but a
all of them are like chomping at the bit
to get back in those gyms and get
everything you know restructured I would
like to see maybe some of the shows get
postponed because then it would give a
lot more competitors more time you know
because god only knows what they're
dealing with in their own personal life
you know with their families being at
home you know I could I'm trying to
think like some of the guys on tour I'm
like I wonder if they're still even
together with their spouse right now
like you know like this is why I smell
opportunity Phil well it has to be right
I mean you have to I mean you have no
choice at this point like like you had
mentioned something a while ago I
believe it was when you weren't with
your present company but it was like was
it right after 9/11 you were working
Morgan Stanley Dean Witter yeah good
good memory or 2008 was my biggest year
ever 2008 I exploded in a wait oh yeah
oh yeah by the way you won't know that
I'm at a too crazy a story here and then
we'll we'll wrap up you know 2001 I was
at the mr. Olympia and it or one I was
at mr. Olympia and I was that was the
time where I wanted to be a competitor I
had a decent physique and I you've seen
some of my pictures it was you know as
the 18 19 year old I had somewhat of a
physique and I went there just to see if
I can get in a mix to want to tee it up
and then it was bodybuilding or was
financial industry Morgan Stanley
recruited me the rest you know it kind
of became a career so yeah this guy
really loves this game my every room of
mine had posters of all the bodybuilders
on the wall so were your apart yeah were
your part and this is no [ __ ] this
is Mina blonds mom I told someone
I'm like have you seen Patrick mint
Davis pictures when he posted them up
the other day and they're like no I'm
like you do realize how tall he is you
actually had pretty good sized proud
tall you were and really good
conditioning how did you I mean not like
how did you do that that like didn't you
find that like what did that make it was
that because you were in the army and
you trained all the time or like like
how did you get because even at 18 you
were like buff like rip and like I said
being as tall as you were or are I don't
see that very often so that that was
impressive why didn't you compete like
like an armed forces show or so I I did
in the army
I did in the army small competitions I
did in the army but nothing post I'm
telling you I came out I what I wanted
to be mr. Olympia I was gonna follow
Arnold's footsteps and I was going to
Century Club Aaron Baker was always
there Chris Cormier was all these guys
but obviously Chris Cormier was
everywhere by the way you just pick a
club he was pretty much like your for a
guy that looks like this every nightclub
I go to after hours I see you everywhere
but that's a whole different story but I
wanted to compete I wanted to go do it I
was obsessed that's the route I was
gonna take and when I went to mr.
Olympia a couple the guys were very
honest about it they said six four and a
half six five is just too tall you know
you're gonna have to put 400 pounds
offseason to win the whole thing do you
really want to take your body through
that and you know I just came back and I
said now I'm gonna go to complete it
from field yeah I think the only person
I've seen that that was that was your
height that had this size was Quincy
Taylor thick to speak by the way Quincy
Taylor and I believe my trainer Hani ran
Bob worked with him during that down
those peak years they get in Quincy I
mean massive so totally know what you're
saying I had to ask because I was just
like wait a minute like you know I come
from basketball background so I see a
lot of tall guys and we lifted weights
and stuff but like but they didn't have
the condition and one of the things that
you know a lot of people ask me
hey you wouldn't think about my physique
my physique and I tell everybody this if
you don't have a foundation of like
certain body parts you don't have to be
massive but you have to be complete like
if you the first thing you decide to go
to the gym if you have legs you're
probably in a better you know way of
like okay we can build it because
everybody can build it upper body so you
got the ladies got the foundation but to
me the other part was can the person get
in shape but is his skin texture nice
mm-hmm and no one ever talks about that
and the one person that talked about
that to me was Peter macguff first time
I talked to him on the phone he called
my he called my job I was running retail
at Bally Total Fitness in in Glendale
Colorado now the total fitness is fill
you how can I help you this is Peter
MacGuffin flex magazine how you doing
among holy smokes I got your magazine
right here with your name editorial was
for me and he gave me nice compliments
and he talked about the skin my skin
texture being kind of like different
like a Sean Ray or you know really nice
and that was something I notice about
those pictures because if your skin
looks rough and rugged yeah some people
like oh yeah it's grainy is like no you
gotta understand like it doesn't motor
graph well therefore it won't sell and
it looks it looks like it's interesting
you know very very disgusting that's why
when people say it grows this man's like
it wasn't overly vascular you know
everything had to be nicely you know
orchestrated and that's something that
skin texture I tell people all the time
I'm like I can see someone off the
street and I look at him in online this
guy could do really well and sometimes I
see that the muscles and I'm like yeah
but he's gonna have a problem with
someone has nicer skin because the skin
has to look extremely healthy and that
goes with the proper diet and your
lifestyle and and somewhat genetics
right because some people I say a couple
people ask about what do I do for my
stretch marks there you go if you have
that across your chest it's not going to
look the same right so you know kudos to
you but I think next time I'm in town
then I got a we got a workout
because I solved it I saw the value
Thema thank you I'm like this guy has a
gym in his own office like this is this
is not fair but I love the fact that
like you know you're you're rooted into
that and you know health and wellness is
always gonna be a part of your regimen
and I don't know but I think that's
great has there's a do your kids like
muscles oh my gosh the middle one
Dylan well you you you may not remember
Dylan but Dylan is Dylan's got a
physique like bo Jackson Dylan's got
this massive bubble butt in his legs
he's got calves that you know I don't
see a lot of six-year-olds having that
camp and he flexes the kids got a
physique not the tall one the older one
no but the middle one he's got a great
physique no not at all not at all I
would make sure his dad ran a contest
that he could win a few million for
first place though oh dude if he sees
you again when you left he's like Daddy
were his arms real what was that I'm
like no it's real he is very big yeah it
was blown away by Phil when Phil was
over something that I will tell you is
the best feeling for me hmm
being the champ is that the kids
reactions dad dad did you see that and I
know sometimes it pisses the dad off
like yeah look at me you know like but
it's not about that dance it's about the
fact that those kids realized right that
took some hard work dude and and that's
a great Avenue for parents to say let's
keep these kids involved in sports and
keep them active you know of course they
got to study and I love the fact that
you're you know so hands-on with them
and the reading and all that stuff but
yeah they got a workout because my my
favorite heroes and I know we gotta wrap
this up but my heroes growing up
definitely Arnold Schwarzenegger because
I mean he was everywhere
ladies but Bo Jackson you mentioned Bo
Johnson if I could have met that man I
mean he you got a kid growing up in
Seattle rooting against the Seahawks
because he ran over Bosworth and I'm
like yeah like you ran him over you know
right he just he was my favorite athlete
growing up Hemi came here in Virginia
with my favorites oh Ken Griffey is a
whole different story
I have to tell you a story I was
beautiful swing of all-time by the way
he could I saw his first home run in the
Kingdome get out of here
my stepdad took me he worked for King
five television as a TV engineer my said
that brought me to the game first home
run and I still remember because my said
they used to bring his radio to the
games like almost like a boom box to the
games and I say pop like why do you
bring the radio to the games it goes
well if we were at home we'd hear the
announcers well therefore I can hear the
game on the earpiece and I just remember
hearing and it was really smart I was
like I said you know because the
play-by-play is much better through the
radio television and I still remember
Dave Niehaus he's no longer with us
but he was the announcer for the
Mariners deep left-center field good-bye
baseball you know like he was just like
and I was an instant fan I still have
that 89 I protect ready you still have
that I was about to buy bgs 10 last week
it wasn't an auction yeah I want I want
that card I know you're a huge fan of
the card game and stuff my cards are
still at my parents house I'm praying
that God they still have them don't I'm
gonna you'll see a grown man cry but
yeah can you be junior by far was my I
need to play baseball but I tell you
what like he was my favorite athlete and
especially growing up in Seattle ken
griffey jr. Edgar Martinez a guy named
Alex Rodriguez got to see him play Jay
Buhner
Randy Johnson saw Randy Johnson throw
that no-hitter as well my stepdad we've
always given up getting seats through
like that through
is because it was an NBC affiliate so
he'd always get by you know some cheap
seats and we would dump but yeah I got
to see all that stuff man and - those
were the days but Pat I know we got a
rep up thank you you got you didn't
disappoint I'm sure you got a lot of
people rumbling I'm sure even my team is
like what the heck is going on but
appreciate you bro
anytime man keep keep that idea here and
we can talk off hours here but keep that
idea here yeah take care feel good have
anybody we'll talk soon okay take care
buh-bye buh-bye